should you take your paycheck in bitcoin
[Music]
cryptocurrencies are clearly here to
stay
almost everybody knows what they are
millions of people have invested in them
and hundreds of thousands of
transactions take place in them every
day but does that mean you should take
your salary in a currency like bitcoin
new york city mayor eric adams is one of
the many who said he would though in
actual fact he had to take his check in
fiat and then convert it
in the early days of crypto when money
sloshed to the technology and when banks
were nervous of opening accounts for the
newly rich entrepreneurs
many offered to pay their workers in the
house money they created
for some this idea seemed bonkers
who ever heard of letting your employer
print the money in which you were paid
unless of course you work for the us
mint
but for maximalists who believe that
eventually all transactions will be in
crypto it makes sense
so what's the downside well of course
there's volatility to consider
wild price swings mean that in dollar
terms your buying power will fluctuate
daily
and even when the roller coaster is on
the way up there are additional taxes to
consider with the crypto gains usually
liable for capital gains tax
those would then be paid on top of your
income tax and vat at the point of sale
so
should you be paid in bitcoin probably
not
but it will depend on your age wealth
location and risk tolerance and if you
really really want to the best way for
now maybe to take your check in us
dollars and then set up a regular
payment service that converts part of it
to the crypto of your choice
in the long run though
who knows
maybe someday we'll all be paid in
crypto
i'm eddie van der waals this is
decrypted for more content like this
follow us on your favorite platforms